[Musica]
buongiorno signor ostuni la sua missione
se dovesse accettarla riguarda lo
scovare una spia all'interno di un party
esclusivo adattare un agente infiltrato
mettere una cimice su un ambasciatore e
sedurre un bersaglio lei o se o
qualsiasi altro membro della squadra
venisse catturato o ucciso il ministro
[ __ ] di essere stato a conoscenza
dell'operazione questo messaggio si
autodistruggerà tra cinque secondi
[Musica]
no no perché porca [ __ ] di silvio e non
lo so non lo sapevo
aspetta sono stephen hawking ma dai
hanno scelto una casa sarà così non va
bene
rifacciamo ripeto io tu con come
funziona tu devi isle aiutare le persone
ad esami che siano
quando vedi qualcuno che potrebbe essere
appunto qualcuno di sospetto tu puoi
premere senza premere e tenere premuto
ministro premi il tasto sinistro e lo
illumini se primi test invece lo spegne
ok ma tool vi era il mio laser lo vedi
solo quando mio marito l'ha se lo vedo
sempre nn breve o kay vuol dire hai
sentito bene breve cioè che vuol dire
che o sto contattando l'agente
infiltrato oppure appunto che sto
cercando di distrarre perché magari io
non sono qui veramente vicino alla gente
infiltrato
ma tu puoi dire vanno una preda a caso
puoi fare fake contati dopo le genti
quindi non so se tu hai fatto davvero 8
può darsi ma non è detto no no ho visto
quello che sbava l'estate ma allora sì
che l'estate possano anche dai dei png
possono anche essere solo prese in mano
ed ora che consiglio cerca di
memorizzare le statue quali sono
all'inizio della partita perché così
quando vedi che uno è stata cambiata per
il rendiconto tranto iniziamo la serie a
farò vedere io comunque è veramente un
gioco ma l'attrice non si pensi
reinventata non sapere di veramente
bello del super divertente
io quindi vedo sempre tu che mi to che
punti le rosa è bello perché non è
scontato che affidò per nulla nel senso
io devo tenere adesso sotto torchio un
1600 così diverse il mio obiettivo è
fare quelle quattro cose che vedete in
alto si sta quindi di mettere una cimice
all'ambasciatore contattare uno dei due
agenti cambiare l'ordine delle statue e
sedurre l'obiettivo questo prima che
gian andrea mi ammazzi c'è lui non sa
chi sono io tra tutti i costi
se lo scopre e mi spara a solo un
proiettile quindi deve essere sicuro a
cui sta sparando sono io veramente
ovviamente se sbaglia obiettivo vinto
fate che la spia a determinati vantaggi
mentre il cecchino diciamo che può
andare un po per esclusione
quindi posso piano piano durante la
partita
comincerei escludere determinati
personaggi della lista dei sospettati
però non è così facile
c'è un signor silvio neanche pareggio
una persona basse da alcuni giorni
tipicamente italiano
io mi sto pagando addosso sai è però
bene un accade che agirà è solo più due
minuti
tu non sai quello che fa 9 non so quello
che hai già fatto che so che
probabilmente non è stata data
ok ma non è ancora contattato gli agenti
infiltrati e probabilmente non è ancora
nemmeno messo una cimice adesso a silvio
e quindi i devoti un cd devo tenere
d'occhio se devo tenere d'occhio perché
io appunto tu lo sai ma mentre tu sai
che l'agente infiltrato
io invece ne ho due possibili e che oggi
è possibile depositare devo tenere
d'occhio due no avevo fatto ha commesso
il bug all'ambasciatore la simil avevo
messo da un'ora e mezza a pochi casi si
che aveva fatto un movimento per sushi
di più e allora pensato e pensa volevo
scegliere lei all'inizio il musicista
allora va bene
bellissimo e vicenza sono occupati dai
gioco è difficilissima in realtà anche
per lo sniper non pensavo fosse così
difficile è sì allora io come snai per
questo sto vedendo quello che vedeva
prima jean e posso colora c'è illuminare
le persone che credo che possano possa
essere lui dei lumini
alle persone che invece non credo
possano essere lui e alla fine comunque
devo sparare a 1 che penso che se lui
non può essere quello che i triangolini
perché quelli quei triangolini sono
tutti tutte persone che lui deve
contante vi interagirci che vede ora lui
sicuramente lì in mezzo ma tipo sono nel
mezzo del cammin di nostra vita
questi che rocking ero symmetra non ci
credo perché quella ho guardato
l'orologio
ero con vi ama gli altri guardano anche
l'orologio che loro possono guardare
l'orologio però tu devi sempre guarda
l'orologio devi tenere con devi vedere
il timer in alto a destra
mamma mia che gioco incasinato che
questo però mi piace e piace anche a me
l'ero blu sul in dio mi ha cambiato
tutto vuoi iniziare a guardare
dall'altra parte dio infatti cos'ha
fatto ho guardato tutt'altra parte ma
mantenendo sempre te
a bordo si e voce bra bra o una seria la
snai per voi come la guardo bene ok le
statue sono
buone devono essere uguali sia a
sinistra che a destra no tu devi
memorizzarle cioè non devono essere
uguali semplicemente di memorizzare i
quali stato ci sono e poi quando quando
vedi che uno è stata cambiata
sai mamma mia il tempo corre ragazzo di
essere più al tempo corre verte
interiore era non vedo però che cosa il
fatto questa veramente impegnando il
difficilissima facendo è stato un
piacere giocare con te forgia ma
purtroppo la vittoria sorpresa riguarda
all'ultimo secondo luogo c'è mi hai
preso proprio sul countdown era 32 barak
che culo incredibile ma allora io avevo
avevo sospettato symmetra è un'altra
solo alla fine che gli scappati ho detto
a mais non ciò che mi mancava soltanto
quello è il e sedurre il bersaglio
un'ultima volta mi ha detto ho
approfittato di una che stava andando lì
detto cambiamo la statua insieme a lei
che magari si confonde e poi vado a
sedurre mancano mi mancano veramente
pochissimo da votato per per il corea
boy mi è andata veramente a culo vabbè
dai amico mio
questa volta è difficile e ce ne sono
due
stavolta non la prendi te lo dico io che
non la prendi avremo dovessi il mio ecco
ma in anno e più brunetta a 22 scipio 16
come allora sì una di due core e amori
chi lo sa e prova un 50 50
mi prendo il mio tempo diciamo prendi
telo dal brand
non è che se lo dici tu banana brad mi
confondo ci ho provato però a non sapevo
dove credi nasconde di sperare e aspetta
volevo bere il mio drink ma mai a morti
mancato niente sedurre il target di la
verità viene imbeccato da un po allora
all col sì perché quando hai fatto
banana brad c'era un coreano che era lì
movimenti strani dell'altro coreano che
non avevo messo in highlight
seguiamo le un po tutte e due ma in
realtà quando hai detto che quando hai
sospettato che il coreano subito detto
che il primo sospetto in realtà è quello
che pt che poi magari poi abbandoni vi
ho detto mi chiamo che ce la faccio per
questo motivo invece no macché niente
c'è stato sedurre il target va bene vai
jean ci sono sarà che io ho sospetti
forti non solo se le prospettive
invece no no come come male visitatori
sviluppato come possibile
cavolo clientele limone dei problemi
ero convintissimo invece perché ho visto
che vi si fa ho fatto subito invece
larini talmente nano che non trovi
questo uso to silvio ragazzi quindi
questa è la partita jean vabbè che ci
devo fare lui è veramente james bond
roba del genere però secondo me non è
male dai comizi no no no siccome ci sono
altre mappe possiamo fare altro a roma
visto che si può variare quindi fatemi
sapere se volete un altro episodio
fighissimo ringrazio per avermi
consigliato gioco per aver partecipato
di niente come se i ragazzi subito
piaciuta c'è un commento mi piace anche
adesso a seconda della descrizione
passate anche dal canale di jean che vi
lascio passati descrizione e vi lascio
che devo andare a scovare la spia
c'è un prossima ragazzi
[Musica]